bine ai revenit la „Înțelegerea informației și computației cuantice", mă numesc John Watrous și sunt directorul tehnic pentru educație
la IBM Quantum. Aceasta este a noua lecție din serie și este prima lecție din a treia unitate, care tratează formularea generală
a informației cuantice. Până acum am folosit formularea simplificată a
informației cuantice, în care stările cuantice sunt reprezentate prin vectori complecși cu norma euclidiană egală cu
unu. Prin contrast, în formularea generală a informației cuantice, stările cuantice sunt reprezentate prin
matrice de un anumit tip, cunoscute sub numele de matrice densitate. Această primă lecție a unității se concentrează specific pe matricele densitate
și vom afla ce sunt și cum funcționează pe măsură ce lecția continuă. Matricele densitate sunt extrem de
utile și oferă diverse avantaje pe care le vom discuta. Ne permit să reprezentăm o
clasă mai largă de stări decât pot vectorii de stare cuantică, inclusiv stări ale sistemelor afectate de zgomot, de exemplu, precum și selecții aleatoare
de stări cuantice. Vom examina și sfera Bloch, care ne oferă o modalitate geometrică foarte frumoasă
și simplă de a gândi despre stările unui qubit și vom vedea cum se conectează cu matricele densitate într-un mod
remarcabil, prin matricele Pauli. În final, vom discuta matricele densitate în contextul sistemelor multiple
și, în special, vom vedea cum ne permit să descriem stări cuantice ale sistemelor privite în izolare chiar și atunci când
sunt corelate cu alte sisteme, inclusiv posibilitatea că sunt întricate cu alte sisteme. Acesta este un lucru important de
putut face și nu se realizează ușor în cadrul formulării simplificate a informației cuantice. Iată o prezentare generală a
lecției: vom începe cu noțiunile de bază ale matricelor densitate, inclusiv definiții relevante și câteva exemple, și vom
discuta și cum se conectează cu vectorii de stare cuantică. Vom vorbi apoi despre combinațiile convexe ale matricelor densitate sau, cu alte cuvinte,
ce se întâmplă când luăm medii ponderate ale matricelor densitate. Vom începe cu un exemplu specific
al așa-numitei stări complet mixte. Vom vedea cum stările probabilistice clasice pot fi privite ca
cazuri speciale ale matricelor densitate și vom discuta cum intervine teorema spectrală din algebra liniară în
acest context. A treia parte a lecției tratează sfera Bloch, care oferă o modalitate geometrică de vizualizare a stărilor unui
singur qubit, după cum am menționat la începutul lecției. În a patra parte a lecției vom vorbi despre cum funcționează matricele densitate pentru sisteme multiple.
Vom discuta stările produs și stările corelate de diferite tipuri, inclusiv stările întricate, precum și
noțiunea de stare redusă, care este o descriere prin matrice densitate a stării unei părți izolate dintr-un sistem compus,
ce poate fi calculată folosind o operație numită urma parțială. Înainte de a ajunge la conținutul tehnic al lecției propriu-zise,
merită să ne oprim câteva momente pentru a motiva utilizarea matricelor densitate. Folosind formularea simplificată
a informației cuantice, care nu implică matrice densitate, putem descrie algoritmi cuantici cum ar fi
algoritmul de factorizare al lui Shor, de exemplu, fără nicio dificultate. Deci de ce ne-am mai obosi cu matricele densitate
sau cu această formulare generală a informației cuantice? Ei bine, există mai multe motive. În primul rând, matricele densitate
reprezintă o clasă mai largă de stări cuantice decât vectorii de stare cuantică, inclusiv stări cuantice în care avem incertitudine sau
aleatorie. Acest lucru este important când vrem să modelăm efectele zgomotului asupra calculelor cuantice, de
exemplu. În al doilea rând, folosind matrice densitate putem descrie stări cuantice ale unor părți izolate din sisteme compuse, cum ar fi
stările sistemelor care sunt întricate cu alte sisteme pe care poate momentan alegem să le ignorăm, după cum am menționat la începutul
lecției. Acest lucru nu se face ușor sau natural în cadrul formulării simplificate a informației
cuantice. Un al treilea motiv este că atunci când folosim matrice densitate, informația clasică apare efectiv ca un
caz special. Astfel, în loc să avem ceea ce este în esență o analogie între stările probabilistice și operațiile
pe de o parte, și vectorii de stare cuantică și operațiile unitare pe de altă parte, avem informația cuantică și clasică
descrise împreună într-un singur cadru matematic, ceea ce este practic esențial pentru studiul matematic
al informației cuantice. Deci, dacă ești serios în privința înțelegerii informației cuantice la nivel matematic, este foarte
recomandat să înveți despre matricele densitate. Să începem cu definiția matricelor
densitate. De dragul definiției, să presupunem că X este un sistem și sigma este mulțimea sa de stări clasice și reamintim că
atunci când folosim această terminologie, presupunem că Sigma este finită și nevidă și, ca întotdeauna, am putea alege
alte nume dacă am vrea. O matrice densitate care descrie o stare a sistemului X este o matrice cu
intrări de numere complexe ale cărei linii și coloane sunt puse în corespondență cu mulțimea sa de stări clasice și, ca să fie clar,
este aceeași corespondență pentru linii și coloane simultan. Aceasta înseamnă că matricele
densitate sunt întotdeauna matrice pătrate și, pe lângă că sunt pătrate, mai trebuie satisfăcute câteva condiții
la care vom ajunge în curând. De obicei se folosesc anumite litere grecești minuscule pentru a denumi
matricele densitate. Rho este adesea prima alegere, iar alte alegeri comune includ sigma minusculă și tau, care sunt prezentate
pe ecran. Aceasta este doar o convenție, dar ca de obicei aceste convenții sunt utile deoarece fac lucrurile mai
ușor recognoscibile. Să vorbim acum despre condițiile sau cerințele pe care trebuie să le satisfacă matricele densitate pentru a fi
matrice densitate valide. Există două astfel de condiții și ceea ce voi face este să le listez mai întâi
și apoi să discut în mai mare detaliu ce înseamnă. Prima condiție este că matricele
densitate trebuie să aibă urma unitară, adică urma egală cu unu. Iar a doua condiție este că
matricele densitate trebuie să fie pozitiv semidefinite și, în ambele cazuri, avem modalități simbolice concise de a exprima
aceste două condiții, prezentate pe ecran. Acum să discut cele două condiții în mai mare detaliu.
Prima condiție se referă la urmă, care este o funcție foarte importantă, definită pentru toate matricele pătrate,
și este pur și simplu suma intrărilor de pe diagonală. Iată o ecuație care exprimă asta
în mod explicit. Acum există destul de multe de spus despre urmă și de ce este importantă, dar deocamdată să observăm
o proprietate foarte de bază a ei, și anume că este o funcție liniară. Alte proprietăți ale urmei vor apărea și le vom discuta pe măsură ce
vor fi necesare, dar pentru a ne menține concentrarea pe matricele densitate, să trecem la a doua cerință, care este că
matricele densitate sunt pozitiv semidefinite. Acesta este și un concept important care apare în multe contexte în
WEBVTT
fizică, chimie, optimizare, machine learning și alte domenii, și poate fi exprimat în mai multe moduri diferite dar
echivalente. O modalitate de a-l exprima este să spunem că o matrice rho este pozitiv semidefinită dacă există o matrice M
astfel încât rho este egală cu M dagger ori M, și se dovedește că nu contează dacă cerem ca M în sine să fie o
matrice pătrat sau dacă renunțăm la această restricție. O altă modalitate de a exprima ce înseamnă ca o matrice rho să fie pozitiv
semidefinită este să spunem că rho este hermitiană, adică este egală cu propriul conjugat transpus, și toți
valorile sale proprii sunt numere reale neneg­ative. În general, matricele hermitiene pot
să aibă numai valori proprii reale, dar pot fi negative; dacă adăugăm restricția suplimentară că niciuna dintre
valorile proprii nu poate fi negativă, obținem matricele pozitiv semidefinite. Apropo, dacă ți se dă
o matrice și vrei să știi dacă este pozitiv semidefinită, poți determina asta folosind această caracterizare. Este destul de ușor să
verifici dacă o matrice este hermitiană — aceasta se poate vedea cu ochiul liber. Este mai dificil să calculezi
valorile proprii, dar nu este prea greu cu un calculator, deoarece există algoritmi foarte eficienți pentru asta.
Ultima caracterizare pe care o voi menționa, deși mai există și altele, este că pentru orice vector coloană s cu
un număr de intrări care corespunde numărului de linii și coloane ale lui rho, inegalitatea prezentată pe
ecran este adevărată. Cu alte cuvinte, s dagger ori rho ori s trebuie să fie un număr real
neneg­ativ. Nu este evident că aceste caracterizări sunt toate echivalente, dar sunt, și să notez explicit că
notația pe care o folosim în mod obișnuit pentru a indica că o matrice rho este pozitiv semidefinită arată ca rho este mai mare
sau egală cu zero, dar aceasta este doar o notație prescurtată și nu înseamnă literal că rho este mai mare decât
sau egală cu zero. rho este o matrice, deci asta n-ar avea sens, și nu înseamnă
că fiecare intrare a lui rho este mai mare sau egală cu zero. În particular, există matrice
pozitiv semidefinite ale căror intrări nu sunt toate neneg­ative și există matrice ale căror intrări sunt toate
neneg­ative, dar care nu sunt pozitiv semidefinite. Ideea din spatele notației este că matricele pozitiv semidefinite
sunt ca analogi matriciali ai numerelor reale neneg­ative, dar aceasta este doar notație și ceea ce înseamnă este
exact ce am discutat deja. Să aruncăm acum o privire la câteva exemple, începând cu un exemplu de
matrice pozitiv semidefinite. De fapt, este destul de ușor să generezi aleatoriu un exemplu de
matrice pozitiv semidefinite alegând pur și simplu o matrice M în mod arbitrar și calculând apoi M dagger ori
M. De exemplu, iată o matrice M care nu este deosebit de specială și, de fapt,
am generat această matrice aleatoriu alegând independent partea reală și imaginară a intrărilor ca numere întregi între -9 și +
9, deci orice tipar sau structură de aici este pur întâmplătoare. Înmulțind
conjugatul transpus al lui M cu M obținem această matrice, care este prin urmare pozitiv
semidefinită. Desigur, există o limită în privința cât de multă perspectivă putem câștiga dintr-un exemplu aleatoriu, dar exhibă câteva
trăsături comune matricelor pozitiv semidefinite în general. În particular, vei observa
că intrările de pe diagonală, adică cele de-a lungul liniei de la stânga sus la dreapta jos, sunt toate numere reale
neneg­ative și, mai mult, intrările de pe diagonala secundară nu sunt prea mari față de intrările de pe diagonala principală
corespunzătoare, adică cea din aceeași linie și aceeași coloană cu intrarea de pe diagonala secundară pe care o analizăm.
Există însă mai mult decât atât și este important să recunoaștem că a fi pozitiv semidefinit este o
proprietate a matricei ca întreg și nu doar o condiție pe intrările individuale. Deci acesta este un exemplu de
matrice pozitiv semidefinite și poți genera cu ușurință alte exemple printr-o metodologie
similară. Să aruncăm acum o privire la câteva exemple de matrice densitate, unde pe lângă condiția de pozitiv semidefinit avem și că urma este
egală cu unu. Iată câteva exemple de matrice densitate 2x2. Urma este egală cu
unu în toate cele patru cazuri și putem vedea, de asemenea, că acestea sunt matrice hermitiene, deci folosind a doua caracterizare a
matricelor pozitiv semidefinite de mai înainte, tot ce rămâne este să verificăm că valorile proprii sunt toate neneg­ative.
Las asta pentru tine să verifici dacă dorești. Pentru matrice 2x2 nu este prea dificil să calculezi valorile proprii manual,
dar poți cere și unui calculator să o facă. De exemplu, poți folosi funcția eigvals din pachetul de algebră liniară
din Python. Putem obține, de asemenea, o matrice densitate luând orice matrice
nenulă pozitiv semidefinite și împărțind-o la urma sa. De exemplu, iată matricea densitate obținută prin
împărțirea exemplului de mai sus la urma sa. Împărțirea la urmă în acest fel
va păstra întotdeauna proprietatea de pozitiv semidefinit și vom obține cu siguranță o matrice cu urma egală cu unu, în virtutea faptului că
urma este o funcție liniară. Aceasta este doar o mică colecție de exemple și vom vedea mai multe pe măsură ce
lecția continuă. Urmează să ne oprim câteva momente pentru a discuta interpretarea sau
semnificația intuitivă a matricelor densitate. Primul lucru de recunoscut este că poate părea puțin neobișnuit
că reprezentăm starea unui sistem cu o matrice în loc de un vector. Prin contrast, în formularea simplificată
a informației cuantice folosim vectori pentru a reprezenta stări, în timp ce matricele, în special matricele unitare,
reprezintă acțiuni sau operații. Acesta este pur și simplu modul în care funcționează matematica și, deși poți
gândi întotdeauna la matrice ca descriind transformări liniare, de obicei nu asociem o semnificație intuitivă directă
transformării liniare asociate cu o matrice densitate dată. Cu toate acestea, faptul că
matricele densitate sunt într-adevăr matrice se dovedește a fi un aspect esențial al lor și vom vedea
asta pe măsură ce continuăm. Dar pentru a menționa pe scurt un singur exemplu deocamdată, valorile proprii ale unei matrice densitate date
se dovedesc a fi foarte importante deoarece descriu cât de multă aleatorie sau incertitudine este inerentă stării
pe care o descrie respectiva matrice densitate. O altă modalitate de a gândi la matricele densitate la un nivel intuitiv
se concentrează pe intrările acestor matrice. Reamintește-ți că liniile și coloanele matricelor densitate sunt puse
în corespondență cu stările clasice ale oricărui sistem despre care vorbim, deci pentru fiecare intrare avem una
WEBVTT
stare clasică corespunzătoare liniei acelei intrări și una corespunzătoare coloanei acelei
intrări. Pentru intrările de pe diagonală, acele două stări clasice sunt aceeași stare și de aceea intrările de pe diagonală sunt
speciale. O modalitate de a interpreta intrările de pe diagonală este că sunt probabilități și, în special, sunt
probabilitățile ca starea clasică corespunzătoare să apară dacă am efectua o măsurătoare în baza standard
pe sistemul a cărui stare cuantică o descriem. Pentru intrările de în afara diagonalei, pe de altă parte, avem o stare clasică corespunzătoare liniei
acelei intrări și o stare clasică diferită corespunzătoare coloanei acelei intrări și, vorbind foarte informal,
aceste intrări descriu gradul în care aceste două stări clasice se află în superpozitie cuantică, precum și
faza relativă dintre ele. Asta ar putea fi mai clar pe măsură ce lecția continuă și vom analiza mai
în detaliu câteva exemple specifice, și detaliile s-ar putea să nu fie clare în acest moment, dar te rog să nu te lași deranjat de asta.
Aceasta este destul de informal și este menită să fie o idee intuitivă de ținut în
minte. Urmează să aruncăm o privire la conexiunea dintre matricele densitate și vectorii de stare cuantică, care sunt vectori coloană
cu norma euclidiană egală cu unu. Doar ca să reamintim definiția matematică: presupunând că avem un
vector de stare cuantică psi care reprezintă starea unui anumit sistem, matricea densitate care reprezintă aceeași
stare cuantică este dată de ket psi ori bra psi, după cum este arătat pe ecran. Ca să fie clar, indicii lui psi
corespund într-un fel stărilor clasice ale oricărui sistem despre care vorbim și aceasta va fi exact aceeași corespondență pe care o avem între
liniile și coloanele matricei noastre densitate și stările clasice ale sistemului. Dacă ne imaginăm că există n
stări clasice ale sistemului și ne gândim la vectorii coloană și linii ca la matrice, atunci ket psi este o matrice n ori unu
și bra psi este o matrice 1 ori n, deci atunci când efectuăm înmulțirea obținem o matrice n ori n.
Aceasta va fi întotdeauna o matrice pozitiv semidefinite tocmai prin forma ei, de fapt, și va avea, de asemenea, urma egală
cu unu în virtutea faptului că psi este un vector unitar, și vom vedea asta în mai mare detaliu
în curând. Stările cuantice reprezentate de matrice densitate de această formă se numesc stări pure.
Iată câteva exemple. Să considerăm mai întâi această stare
de aici, care este cumva ca starea plus, cu excepția că intrarea corespunzătoare stării clasice unu este
imaginară. Dacă calculăm conjugatul transpus, vom obține un semn minus deoarece conjugatul complex al lui i este
minus i, și dacă efectuăm înmulțirea vom obține matricea prezentată pe ecran. Este hermitiană, după cum putem
vedea imediat, și se întâmplă să aibă o valoare proprie egală cu unu și o valoare proprie egală cu
zero, deci este pozitiv semidefinite și urma sa este egală cu unu, deci este o matrice densitate,
după cum era de așteptat. Putem calcula matricele densitate corespunzătoare bazei standard și bazelor plus-minus într-un mod similar, iar acele matrice densitate
sunt prezentate aici. Și iată încă un exemplu de vector de stare cuantică, care a apărut
în prima lecție a seriei, și dacă calculăm conjugatul transpus și înmulțim,
vom obține matricea densitate prezentată aici. Din nou, este hermitiană și are
urma egală cu unu, și dacă calculezi valorile proprii vei găsi că din nou are o valoare proprie egală cu unu și una
egală cu zero. Apropo, aceasta este o caracteristică comună tuturor stărilor pure: au întotdeauna o valoare proprie
egală cu unu și restul valorilor proprii sunt toate zero. În general, pentru un vector de stare cuantică
complet arbitrar psi cu orice număr de intrări, dacă înmulțim ket psi cu bra psi vom obține o
matrice densitate care arată astfel. Observă în particular că intrările de pe diagonală sunt întotdeauna una dintre
intrările lui psi înmulțită cu propriul conjugat complex, pe care o putem exprima alternativ ca valoarea absolută la pătrat a acelei intrări, și aceasta este
o modalitate de a vedea că urma va fi întotdeauna egală cu unu. Este, de asemenea, consistent cu observația pe care am făcut-o mai devreme în lecție despre
intrările de pe diagonală ale unei matrice densitate spunându-ne care ar fi probabilitățile de a vedea fiecare stare clasică posibilă
dacă am efectua o măsurătoare în baza standard. Și o ultimă observație:
nu există probleme legate de fazele globale pentru matricele densitate. Două stări cuantice sunt identice dacă și numai dacă matricele lor
densitate sunt egale. În particular, să presupunem că avem doi vectori de stare cuantică psi și phi care
sunt echivalenți până la o fază globală, ceea ce înseamnă că putem exprima unul dintre ei, fie phi, ca celălalt înmulțit cu
un număr complex de pe cercul unitar. Dacă calculăm reprezentarea prin matrice densitate a lui phi, ceea ce vom
găsi este că factorul de fază globală este înmulțit cu propriul său conjugat complex, ceea ce ne dă unu, deci
dispare efectiv și rămânem cu exact aceeași matrice densitate pe care o obținem din psi. Deci acesta este un
mic bonus, și mai general, nu există niciun fel de problemă privind echivalența până la faze globale atunci când
lucrăm cu matrice densitate. Aceasta este practic o degenerare care există atunci când folosim vectori de stare cuantică mai degrabă
decât matrice densitate pentru a reprezenta stări cuantice. Matricele densitate posedă o proprietate cheie, și anume că combinațiile convexe
ale matricelor densitate reprezintă selecții probabilistice sau aleatoare de stări
cuantice. O altă modalitate de a spune asta este că matricele densitate pot fi mediate împreună într-un mod semnificativ, ceea ce
nu putem face cu vectorii de stare cuantică. Ca să explicăm asta în mai mare detaliu, să începem cu situația în care
avem două matrice densitate rho și sigma care reprezintă stări cuantice ale unui sistem. Să ne imaginăm că
sistemul este pregătit în starea rho cu probabilitatea p, pentru o anumită alegere a lui p între zero și unu, și altfel
sistemul este pregătit în starea sigma. De exemplu, poate p este 1/2, deci
ne putem imagina că cineva aruncă un ban corect și dacă iese cap efectuează un proces care lasă sistemul în
starea rho, iar altfel, dacă banul cade pe pajură, efectuează un alt proces care lasă sistemul în
starea sigma. Întrebarea acum este: care este starea sistemului? Ca să fie clar,
suntem interesați de starea sistemului în izolare, ignorând orice altă informație care ar putea exista despre
care pregătire a fost efectuată. De exemplu, imaginează-ți că nu avem acces la ban sau la
memoria celui care a efectuat pregătirea stării, și răspunsul la acea întrebare este că este pur și simplu media ponderată a celor două
WEBVTT
matrice densitate: p ori rho plus 1 - p ori sigma. Aceasta este complet
analogă cu ceea ce am avea dacă rho și sigma n-ar fi matrice densitate, ci vectori de probabilitate
reprezentând stări probabilistice. Deci nu este ceva șocant sau misterios, ci mai degrabă ceva
familiar din teoria probabilităților. Facem acest tip de mediere tot timpul când calculăm probabilități și gândim
la selecții aleatoare clasice, iar ideea este că funcționează și pentru matricele densitate, dar observă că nu
funcționează pentru vectorii de stare cuantică. Adică nu poți face în general media a doi vectori de stare
cuantică în acest fel și să speri să obții un vector de stare cuantică valid, și dacă încerci vei obține de obicei un vector care
nu are norma euclidiană egală cu unu. Cu matricele densitate, însă, mediile ponderate ca aceasta vor fi întotdeauna
matrice densitate valide și, mai important, matricea densitate obținută va reprezenta acea selecție aleatoare într-un
mod semnificativ. Aceasta se generalizează la selecții aleatoare în care există mai mult de două
alternative. În particular, dacă avem m matrice densitate posibile și un vector de probabilitate cu m intrări, câte una
pentru fiecare matrice densitate, și un sistem este pregătit în fiecare stare posibilă cu probabilitatea corespunzătoare,
atunci media ponderată a acelor matrice densitate descrie starea rezultantă a sistemului. Apropo, când
ne referim la o combinație convexă de matrice densitate, asta vrem să spunem. O combinație convexă este pur și simplu o combinație liniară
în care coeficienții formează un vector de probabilitate. Aceasta va fi întotdeauna o matrice
densitate, și o modalitate simplă și concisă de a spune asta în termeni matematici este că mulțimea tuturor matricelor densitate
corespunzătoare unui sistem dat este o mulțime convexă. Deci, dacă avem să zicem m vectori de stare cuantică
psi 0 până la psi m minus unu, împreună cu probabilitățile p 0 până la p m minus unu care formează colectiv un
vector de probabilitate, și un sistem este pregătit în starea psi k cu probabilitatea pk pentru fiecare k, atunci
starea rezultantă a sistemului este descrisă de matricea densitate prezentată pe ecran. În particular, nu facem media
vectorilor de stare cuantică înșiși, ci mai degrabă facem media matricelor densitate corespunzătoare.
În general, o stare ca aceasta nu va avea o reprezentare ca un singur vector de stare
cuantică, cu excepția cazului în care se întâmplă ceva trivial, cum ar fi că toți vectorii de stare cuantică sunt echivalenți până la o fază globală sau că toți în afară de unul dintre
probabilitățile sunt zero. Nu vom obține o stare cuantică pură dintr-un astfel de proces, ci vom obține ceea ce se numește
o stare cuantică mixtă, unde există o incertitudine inerentă. Să aruncăm o privire la un exemplu simplu.
Să presupunem că avem un qubit și cu probabilitatea 1/2 qubit-ul este pregătit în starea zero, iar altfel
este pregătit în starea plus. Iată matricea densitate pe care o obținem prin mediere, după cum am
descris. Calculăm matricele densitate corespunzătoare celor două stări posibile, înmulțim cu probabilitățile corespunzătoare și adunăm
rezultatele. Ceea ce obținem este într-adevăr o matrice densitate: este hermitiană, urma este egală cu unu
și dacă calculezi valorile proprii ale acestei matrice vei obține două numere reale pozitive, și se întâmplă să fie două numere care ar trebui să fie deja familiare
acum: cosinus pătrat din pi/8 și sinus pătrat din pi/8, adică aproximativ 0.85 și
0.15. Nu există o reprezentare cu un singur vector de stare cuantică a acestei stări, deci nu este o stare pură. Urmează să aruncăm o privire la
o matrice densitate particulară care reprezintă o stare cuantică a unui singur qubit, cunoscută sub denumirea de starea complet mixtă.
Această stare apare frecvent, deci este bine să îi avem un nume, și este, de asemenea, un bun exemplu deoarece
ilustrează o trăsătură importantă a matricelor densitate. Există de fapt o stare complet mixtă definită în mod analog pentru orice
sistem, dar deocamdată ne vom concentra pe această stare pentru un singur qubit, doar ca să păstrăm lucrurile
simple. Să presupunem că setăm aleatoriu starea unui qubit la fie starea zero, fie starea unu, fiecare cu
probabilitate egală cu 1/2, la fel ca un bit aleatoriu uniform. Putem calcula reprezentarea prin matrice densitate a acestei
stări în modul obișnuit: luăm media celor două reprezentări prin matrice densitate ale stărilor. Iată cum
arată asta în formă matriceală și ceea ce obținem este matricea identitate împărțită la
doi. Această stare este cunoscută sub denumirea de starea complet mixtă și reprezintă practic o
incertitudine completă sau maximă despre un qubit, la fel cum un vector de probabilitate uniform reprezintă incertitudinea maximă în
contextul probabilistic clasic. În general, pentru un sistem arbitrar, starea complet mixtă este
starea obținută alegând uniform o stare din baza standard, iar reprezentarea prin matrice densitate va fi
matricea identitate împărțită la dimensiune, sau echivalent, la numărul de stări clasice ale acelui
sistem. În acest moment, aceasta este doar terminologie, dar dacă schimbăm puțin configurarea vom vedea o trăsătură importantă a
matricelor densitate. În particular, să presupunem că schimbăm procedura și, în locul
stărilor standard zero și unu, substituim stările plus și minus. De data aceasta începem cu
expresia prezentată pe ecran, dar dacă parcurgem aritmetica obținem exact aceeași
matrice densitate. Este matricea identitate împărțită la doi, deci este aceeași stare ca înainte:
starea complet mixtă. Aceasta este, cum se spune, o caracteristică și nu un bug. Cele două proceduri sunt de fapt
diferite, dar dacă tot ce ai este qubit-ul rezultant, nu există nicio modalitate fizică prin care să le poți distinge
chiar și în sens statistic. De exemplu, dacă ai efectua o măsurătoare în baza standard pe acest qubit
după ce a fost efectuată prima procedură, ai obține evident rezultatul zero cu probabilitate 1/2 și rezultatul unu cu probabilitate 1/2, dar ai obține și
exact aceleași probabilități pentru rezultate pentru a doua procedură, și același lucru este valabil pentru orice alt test pe care l-ai
concepe, presupunând că testezi doar qubit-ul însuși. În general, matricele densitate nu descriu cum a fost pregătit un sistem,
ci îți spun doar ce se va întâmpla dacă faci lucruri acelui sistem pe viitor, fie că efectuezi
operații, fie măsurători. Și de fapt, matricele densitate sunt perfecte în această
privință: dacă două alternative diferite duc la aceeași matrice densitate, nu pot fi discriminate chiar
nici statistic. Dar dacă cele două matrice densitate sunt diferite, va exista o modalitate de a le discrimina, nu
neapărat definitiv, ci în sens statistic. Când folosim formularea generală a informației
WEBVTT
cuantice, informația clasică apare în esență ca un caz special și voi explica acum cum
funcționează asta. Mai exact, vom vedea cum pot fi reprezentate stările probabilistice prin matrice
densitate. Să începem cu stările clasice, pornind de la un exemplu simplu.
Iată reprezentările prin matrice densitate ale stărilor zero și unu din baza standard ale unui
qubit. Asociem aceste stări cu stările clasice 0 și 1, deci putem gândi la aceste matrice densitate ca
reprezentând acele stări. Aceasta este foarte simplu și putem generaliza cu ușurință
exemplul. Dacă avem un sistem a cărui mulțime de stări clasice este Sigma, atunci starea clasică a este reprezentată prin sau
este asociată cu matricea densitate ket a bra a. Acea matrice are un singur unu în
intrarea de pe diagonală a cărei linie și coloană corespund stării clasice a, și orice altă intrare este
zero. Stările probabilistice sunt reprezentate prin combinații convexe ale matricelor de această formă, ceea ce este natural
dată ce știm cum funcționează matricele densitate și în particular că combinațiile convexe ale matricelor densitate reprezintă selecții aleatoare sau
probabilistice ale stărilor cuantice. De exemplu, să presupunem că
avem un sistem X a cărui mulțime de stări clasice include numerele întregi de la 0 la n minus unu, pentru un număr întreg pozitiv n.
Desigur, nu se pierde generalitate presupunând că mulțimea noastră de stări clasice are această formă. Dacă am avea o
altă mulțime de stări clasice, am putea pur și simplu redenumi stările clasice în acest mod, și este adesea destul de convenabil să facem presupunerea că mulțimile noastre de stări clasice
arată astfel, în mare parte deoarece asta face mai ușoară scrierea explicită a lucrurilor în termeni de
vectori și matrice. Presupunând că avem o stare probabilistică a sistemului X
reprezentată de un vector de probabilitate în modul obișnuit, putem asocia această stare probabilistică cu o matrice
densitate, după cum este arătat pe ecran. Luăm media ponderată a matricelor densitate corespunzătoare
diferitelor stări clasice și ceea ce obținem este o matrice densitate diagonală. În particular, vedem probabilitățile
de-a lungul diagonalei acestei matrice și orice altă intrare este egală cu zero. Desigur, aceasta este o matrice densitate
și ne așteptăm la asta, dar o putem razona și direct: este o matrice hermitiană, urma sa
este egală cu unu deoarece probabilitățile însumate dau unu, și în cazul unei matrice diagonale valorile proprii sunt intrările de pe diagonală
și sunt toate neneg­ative deoarece sunt probabilități. Observă, de asemenea, că orice
matrice densitate diagonală, adică una ale cărei intrări din afara diagonalei sunt toate zero, trebuie să arate astfel. Deci, pe scurt,
stările probabilistice pot fi asociate cu matrice densitate diagonale. Observă că aceasta este consistent cu
interpretarea informală a intrărilor matricelor densitate pe care am menționat-o la începutul lecției. În particular, nimic nu este în
superpozitie cuantică: este practic doar aleatorie clasică și, corespunzător, toate intrările din afara diagonalei
sunt zero. Mai devreme în această serie am discutat teorema spectrală și am făcut asta
specific pentru matricele unitare în contextul estimării fazei. Teorema spectrală este
mai generală decât atât, adică ne spune ceva despre o clasă mai largă de matrice decât doar matricele unitare.
În particular, se aplică unei clase de matrice numite matrice normale, care includ toate matricele hermitiene ca
și matricele unitare. Ceea ce vom face acum este să aruncăm o privire la o altă afirmație a acestei teoreme, de data aceasta concentrându-ne pe
matricele pozitiv semidefinite, și apoi vom vedea că ne spune ceva foarte interesant și esențial despre matricele
densitate. Să presupunem că P este orice matrice pozitiv semidefinite, deci aceasta include orice matrice densitate, dar și orice
matrice pozitiv semidefinite care nu are urma egală cu unu. P este pozitiv semidefinite, deci trebuie să fie
pătrat, adică n ori n pentru o anumită alegere a lui n, și va trebui să ne referim la acel număr n, deci fie n
ales corespunzător, sau altă modalitate de a spune toate acestea este: să presupunem că P este n ori n. Ceea ce ne spune teorema în acest caz este că
trebuie să existe o bază ortonormată de vectori, pe care o vom denumi psi 0 până la psi n minus unu, împreună cu numere reale neneg­ative
lambda 0 până la lambda n minus unu, astfel încât P poate fi exprimată după cum este arătat
pe ecran. Cu alte cuvinte, dacă înmulțim fiecare lambda k cu ket psi k ori bra psi k și
sumăm după toți k de la 0 la n minus unu, vom obține P. Aceasta se numește o descompunere spectrală
a lui P. Fiecare lambda k este în mod necesar o valoare proprie a lui P și fiecare psi este un vector propriu unitar al lui P
corespunzând acelei valori proprii. Dacă te uiți înapoi la lecția 7 despre estimarea fazei, vei găsi o teoremă similară
pentru matricele unitare. Acolo valorile proprii sunt numere complexe de pe cercul unitar, mai degrabă decât numere reale neneg­ative,
dar altfel este aceeași idee, și acestea sunt cu adevărat doar două cazuri speciale ale unei teoreme mai generale cunoscute ca
teorema spectrală. Nu funcționează pentru orice matrice, trebuie ca matricea să comute cu propriul ei
conjugat transpus și asta înseamnă ca o matrice să fie normală, dar avem de fapt întotdeauna asta
atât pentru matricele unitare cât și pentru matricele pozitiv semidefinite, și pentru matricele hermitiene în general,
unde vom avea întotdeauna valori proprii reale, dar nu neapărat neneg­ative. Deci aceasta este o afirmație a
teoremei spectrale doar pentru matricele pozitiv semidefinite, și acum să vedem ce ne spune despre matricele
densitate. Ceea ce ne spune este că pentru o matrice densitate n ori n arbitrară putem exprima întotdeauna acea matrice ca o combinație convexă
de n stări pure și, mai mult, putem lua acele n stări pure să fie
ortogonale. Aceasta urmează destul de direct din teoremă împreună cu un fapt de bază din algebra liniară, care este că
suma valorilor proprii ale oricărei matrice este întotdeauna egală cu urma acelei matrice. Cu alte cuvinte, tot ce facem cu adevărat
este să redenumim valorile proprii p 0 până la p n minus unu și apoi să observăm că atunci când facem asta și
adunăm acele valori proprii într-un vector n-dimensional, obținem în mod necesar un vector de probabilitate deoarece toate trebuie să fie neneg­ative și suma lor egală
cu urma lui rho, care este unu deoarece rho este o matrice densitate. Deci asta este destul de simplu, dar este
cu adevărat fundamental din punct de vedere conceptual. Ceea ce ne spune este că orice matrice densitate, oricât
de complicată ar părea, ar putea proveni din selectarea mai întâi a unei baze ortonormate a oricărui sistem
despre care vorbim și apoi alegerea aleatoare a unei stări cuantice din acea bază conform unei alegeri pentru
WEBVTT
probabilități. Dacă nu este imediat clar la suprafață de ce este asta interesant sau important, este în regulă, dar folosim acest
fapt foarte frecvent când raționăm despre matricele densitate și, de fapt, exprimarea unei matrice densitate date
în acest mod este adesea primul lucru pe care îl facem când vrem să o înțelegem
mai bine. Iată un exemplu. Reamintește-ți matricea densitate la care am ajuns mai devreme, unde alegeam aleatoriu între
starea zero și starea plus, fiecare cu probabilitate 1/2, care după cum am calculat are o matrice densitate care
arată astfel. Starea zero și starea plus nu sunt ortogonale, deci aceasta nu este o
descompunere spectrală, dar dacă calculăm una, ceea ce putem face cu un calculator sau manual în cazuri ca acesta, atunci ceea ce
obținem este această expresie a matricei noastre densitate, unde valorile proprii sunt acele numere care tot apar și
unde vectorii proprii corespunzători pot fi aleși după cum este arătat în partea de jos a ecranului. Și din nou, am văzut acești vectori înainte, de exemplu în
contextul jocului CHSH din lecția 4. Deci este interesant: conform
expresiei originale, această stare este ceea ce obținem alegând uniform între două stări, starea zero și
starea plus, dar de fapt obținem exact aceeași matrice densitate alegând aleatoriu între două stări pure
dar cu o ponderare foarte puternică către una dintre ele: aproximativ 85% pentru prima și doar aproximativ 15% pentru
a doua. Deci, în un anumit sens, există de fapt mai puțină aleatorie inerentă stării decât ar fi putut părea inițial.
Există o modalitate geometrică foarte frumoasă de a gândi și vizualiza stările cuantice ale unui singur qubit, cunoscută
sub denumirea de sfera Bloch. Funcționează doar pentru un singur qubit; pentru sisteme cu trei
sau mai multe stări clasice, incluzând doi sau mai mulți qubiți împreună, nu mai funcționează, deci este destul de limitată, dar
cu toate acestea este o modalitate excelentă de a gândi despre stările unui singur qubit. Putea fi introdusă
încă din prima lecție a seriei despre sisteme simple, dar nu este cu adevărat esențială pentru înțelegerea funcționării informației cuantice și are, de asemenea, o
conexiune foarte frumoasă cu matricele densitate, deci se încadrează natural în această lecție. Și de fapt, o voi explica
într-un mod oarecum diferit față de cum este poate cel mai adesea explicată, folosind matricele densitate pentru a o
deriva efectiv. Deci, dacă ești deja familiarizat cu sfera Bloch, această explicație poate fi puțin diferită față de
modul în care ai aflat prima dată despre ea, dar în final ar trebui, desigur, să fie echivalentă. Vom începe prin a gândi despre
stările pure posibile ale unui qubit, mai întâi reprezentate prin vectori de stare
cuantică. Până la o fază globală, orice vector de stare cuantică al unui qubit poate fi exprimat după cum
este arătat pe ecran. Mai precis, avem două numere reale theta și phi și le vom gândi
ca pe niște unghiuri exprimate în radiani. Primul număr, theta, este între 0 și pi, sau echivalent, este un
unghi între 0 și 180°, iar al doilea număr, phi, este între 0 și 2 pi, incluzând 0 dar nu 2
pi, deci este orice unghi între 0 și 360°. Intrarea zero a vectorului nostru este
cosinus de theta / 2, deci este un număr real între 0 și 1 și, în particular, este în mod necesar neneg­ativ,
iar intrarea unu a vectorului nostru este e la puterea i ori phi ori sinus de theta / 2, și poate fi
orice număr complex pe sau în interiorul cercului unitar complex. Acesta este întotdeauna un vector unitar, adică
un vector de stare cuantică valid, și pentru orice vector de stare cuantică al unui qubit dat, putem găsi întotdeauna
un vector de această formă care este echivalent cu acel vector până la o fază globală. În particular, putem întotdeauna
înmulți vectorul dat cu o fază globală pentru a face intrarea zero un număr real neneg­ativ, alegem orice
theta care funcționează pentru a obține acea intrare și apoi alegem phi pentru a potrivi intrarea unu. Magnitudinea intrării unu
va coincide întotdeauna în mod necesar cu sinusul lui theta / 2, prin ipoteza că am început cu un vector
unitar. Acum, nu este exact cazul că theta și phi sunt determinați în mod unic de orice vector de stare cuantică cu care am început,
dar aproape: va exista întotdeauna o valoare unică a lui theta între zero și pi care funcționează
și de obicei există o valoare unică a lui phi care funcționează, dar în două cazuri speciale asta nu este adevărat. În particular, dacă am început cu o
stare din baza standard, atunci theta va fi fie zero, fie pi, și în ambele cazuri nu contează de fapt care este phi, este
complet irelevant. Când theta este zero, cosinusul lui theta / 2 este 1 și sinusul lui theta / 2
este zero, deci înmulțim e la puterea i ori phi cu zero, deci nu contează ce valoare are phi.
Iar dacă theta este pi, atunci de data aceasta cosinusul este zero și sinusul este unu, deci avem e la puterea i ori phi ori ket 1, dar
toți acești vectori sunt echivalenți până la o fază globală, deci din nou nu contează ce valoare are phi. Totuși, dacă theta se află strict
între zero și pi, va exista întotdeauna o valoare unică a lui phi care funcționează, și apropo, această posibilă
degenerare în valoarea lui phi pentru cele două cazuri speciale va face sens perfect atunci când vom vedea imaginea geometrică
imediat. Să calculăm acum matricea densitate asociată cu un vector de stare de forma pe care tocmai
am identificat-o. Deci aceasta va fi o stare pură a unui qubit. Pentru a face asta, înmulțim vectorul
cu conjugatul său transpus ca de obicei, și pe ecran este o expresie a matricei pe care o obținem calculând conjugatul
transpus și efectuând înmulțirea. Acum, la fel ca orice matrice 2x2,
există o modalitate unică de a obține această matrice luând o combinație liniară a matricelor Pauli
incluzând matricea identitate. În particular, putem obține această matrice alegând coeficienții
matricelor Pauli după cum este arătat pe ecran. Punem un doi în numitor deoarece asta va face
totul să funcționeze bine; nimic nu ne obligă să facem asta, dar putem și va fi util. Dar în afară
de această alegere cosmetică, nu există nicio libertate: aceasta este singura modalitate de a obține această matrice luând o combinație liniară a matricelor Pauli,
deoarece matricele Pauli incluzând matricea identitate formează o bază pentru spațiul vectorial al tuturor matricelor 2x2. O modalitate
de a verifica corectitudinea acestei expresii este să folosești niște identități trigonometrice de bază și, în particular, dacă mă dau la o parte pentru
un moment, avem câteva identități care vor funcționa. Deci, dacă ești motivat, pune pe pauză videoclipul sau
fă o captură de ecran și vezi dacă poți obține a doua expresie a matricei densitate de jos din prima. Deci, rezumând, orice stare pură a unui
qubit exprimată ca matrice densitate poate fi scrisă ca o combinație liniară a matricelor Pauli, după cum este arătat pe
WEBVTT
ecran, pentru theta între 0 și pi și phi între 0 și 2 pi. Observă că avem exact aceeași
degenerare ca înainte, și anume că phi este irelevant când theta este fie zero, fie pi, și de data aceasta putem
vedea asta mai clar deoarece sinusul lui theta este zero în acele două cazuri și altfel nu. Merită menționat
că în această formulă theta apare ca argument al funcțiilor sinus și cosinus mai degrabă decât theta / 2 ca în versiunea originală cu vectorul de stare cuantică,
și asta se datorează utilizării acelor identități trigonometrice, primele trei dintre care sunt practic
rearanjări ale așa-numitelor formule pentru unghiul dublu. Deci unghiul se dublează efectiv, și acum suntem în sfărșit pregătiți
să vorbim despre sfera Bloch în sine. Să ne concentrăm pe cei trei coeficienți ai matricelor Pauli non-identitate
din numărătorul expresiei matricei noastre densitate, deci ignorăm cei doi din
numitor. Ignorăm de asemenea matricea identitate deoarece coeficientul acesteia nu se schimbă niciodată; asta se întâmplă deoarece acel
coeficient este determinat de urma oricărei matrice pe care o exprimăm, iar matricele densitate au întotdeauna urma egală
cu unu. Imaginează-ți acum că avem trei axe etichetate x, y și z, orientate conform
așa-numitei reguli a mâinii drepte, și considerăm punctul ale cărui coordonate corespund celor trei coeficienți. Și ca să fie clar, acesta
este spațiul tridimensional obișnuit despre care vorbim, unde coordonatele sunt întotdeauna numere reale. Coordonata
x corespunde coeficientului matricei Pauli sigma X în numărătorul expresiei noastre, care este întotdeauna un număr real deoarece matricele
densitate sunt hermitiene, și la fel pentru Y și Z. Ceea ce constatăm este că punctul pe care
îl obținem se află întotdeauna pe sfera unitate, adică sfera cu raza egală cu
unu. Și în particular, este punctul pe care îl obținem dacă începem de la punctul în care axa z pozitivă intersectează sfera,
pe care îl putem gândi ca Polul Nord, rotim în jos spre axa x pozitivă cu un unghi theta și apoi
rotim spre axa y pozitivă, adică spre est, cu un unghi phi. În acest context, unghiul theta se numește
unghi polar, care este ușor de reținut deoarece pornește de la pol, iar phi se numește unghi
azimutal, și împreună aceste două unghiuri reprezintă coordonate sferice pentru punctele de pe sfera unitate. Și dacă
ai vrea, ai putea permite și variația razei pentru a reprezenta puncte arbitrare în spațiul tridimensional, dar ne concentrăm pe punctele de pe
sfera unitate unde raza este egală cu unu. Poți gândi theta și ca reprezentând latitudinea, cu excepția că mergem
de la 0 la 180° de la Polul Nord la Polul Sud, mai degrabă decât ±90° față de ecuator, și phi reprezintă
longitudinea, unde definim practic meridianul prim ca meridianul care intersectează axa x
pozitivă. Dacă ești ca mine, apropo, și ți-e greu să ții minte care este latitudinea și care este longitudinea, poate fi util să îți amintești
că longitudinea corespunde intervalului mai lung: 2 pi, față de
pi. Oricum, punctul pe care îl obținem pe sfera unitate din vectorul nostru de stare cuantică psi gândindu-ne la coordonate în acest
mod este reprezentarea sfera Bloch a stării cuantice corespunzătoare lui psi, și când ne gândim la întreaga
sferă tridimensională unitate în acest mod obținem sfera Bloch. Din punct de vedere geometric, este pur și simplu o sferă unitate
în spațiul tridimensional obișnuit, dar de fapt aceasta este geometria stărilor
unui qubit. Există o corespondență unu la unu perfectă: fiecare stare pură a unui qubit corespunde unui punct unic pe
sferă și fiecare punct de pe sferă reprezintă o stare unică a unui qubit până la o fază globală. Când lucrăm cu
vectori de stare cuantică, această corespondență mai poartă și alte denumiri; se mai numește și sfera Poincaré
de exemplu, dar în contextul informației cuantice este în general numită sfera Bloch. Observă că putem vedea acum
degenerarea în unghiul phi destul de clar, deoarece longitudinea nu are sens la Polul Nord și Polul Sud, dar în afară
de poli, fiecare punct de pe Pământ are coordonate unice în termeni de latitudine și longitudine, și același lucru se întâmplă și aici. Deci acesta este modul în care
funcționează sfera Bloch în general. Să aruncăm acum o privire la câteva exemple specifice de stări ale unui qubit și
unde se situează pe sfera Bloch. Să începem cu baza standard. Acestea sunt punctele obținute
când unghiul polar theta este zero pentru starea zero și pi pentru starea unu. Acestea sunt cele două cazuri în care
unghiul azimutal phi este irelevant, după cum am discutat deja. Putem, de asemenea, exprima matricele densitate corespunzătoare ca combinații liniare
ale matricelor Pauli și, în oricare dintre modalități, concluzionăm că aceste două stări corespund Polului Nord și
Polului Sud al sferei Bloch. Starea zero este sus și starea unu este
jos. Urmează să găsim stările plus și minus pe sfera Bloch. Din nou, putem gândi la
vectorii de stare cuantică sau la matricele densitate. Pentru vectorii de stare cuantică, de data aceasta unghiul polar theta trebuie să fie pi
/ 2 pentru ca intrarea zero să fie 1/√2; unghiul azimutal phi trebuie să fie zero
pentru starea plus deoarece intrarea unu este pozitivă pentru starea plus și trebuie să fie pi, adică 180°, pentru starea minus
deoarece aceea este negativă în acel caz. Deci aceste două puncte se află pe
ecuatorul sferei Bloch. Starea plus este acolo unde axa x pozitivă intersectează sfera, iar starea minus este de cealaltă parte, acolo unde
axa x negativă intersectează sfera. Echivalent, putem vedea și din expresiile cu matrice Pauli pentru
matricele densitate corespunzătoare că coordonatele Y și Z sunt ambele zero, în timp ce coordonatele x sunt pozitive și negative
1. Un alt exemplu este baza plus I minus I, care este similară cu baza plus minus, cu excepția că înmulțim și
intrarea unu cu i, unitatea imaginară. Am văzut starea plus I mai devreme în lecție, iar starea minus I este definită
în mod analog. Unghiul polar theta este același ca pentru stările plus și minus: pi /
2, iar de data aceasta trebuie să alegem unghiul azimutal phi astfel încât să obținem i și minus i mai degrabă decât 1 și minus 1,
și pi / 2 și 3 pi / 2 sunt alegerile corecte pentru asta. Din nou, putem privi și la
descrierile prin matrice densitate ale acestor stări și lucrurile sunt destul de similare cu exemplele anterioare, cu excepția că de data aceasta avem matricea Pauli Y în locul
lui Z sau X. Deci, pe sfera Bloch, aceste două stări sunt localizate acolo unde axa y
intersectează sfera, și dacă curățăm puțin lucrurile putem vedea mai clar cum cele șase stări pe care tocmai le-am discutat
se raportează una la alta. Iată doar un exemplu suplimentar, sau mai degrabă o clasă de exemple. Considerăm
vectorii de stare ale unui qubit care au apărut mai devreme și în lecția 4, unde intrarea zero este cosinusul lui alpha pentru un număr real alpha și intrarea unu
WEBVTT
este sinusul lui alpha. Putem, apropo, restricționa atenția la valori ale lui alpha între zero și pi, deoarece orice
altă valoare a lui alpha ne va da un vector echivalent până la o fază globală cu unul în care alpha se află în acest
interval. Dacă calculăm matricele densitate asociate cu aceste stări, exprimate ca combinații liniare ale matricelor Pauli,
obținem expresia prezentată pe ecran. Acel calcul nu este arătat aici, dar acesta este ceea ce ar trebui
să obții dacă parcurgi. Și ceea ce constatăm este că aceste stări formează un așa-numit cerc mare care trece
prin poli. Specific, pornind de la Polul Nord când alpha este zero, coborând pe meridianul prim și
ajungând la Polul Sud când alpha este pi / 2, și apoi înapoi la Polul Nord de pe cealaltă parte a sferei, pe măsură ce alpha variază de la pi / 2 la
pi. Și totul are sens deoarece, în primul rând, aceștia sunt vectori reali, deci partea imaginară este întotdeauna zero, și în al doilea rând,
unghiul alpha se dublează efectiv pe sfera Bloch, și din nou asta poate fi explicat prin utilizarea
formulelor pentru unghiul dublu. Am văzut că sfera Bloch oferă o reprezentare geometrică foarte frumoasă pentru stările pure ale unui
qubit, unde fiecare punct de pe sferă corespunde unei stări pure unice a unui qubit și viceversa.
Când ne referim la bila Bloch, vorbim despre toate punctele de pe sfera Bloch, dar și despre punctele
din interiorul ei. Punctele din interiorul bilei Bloch corespund și ele stărilor unui qubit,
mai exact stărilor care nu sunt pure. Cu alte cuvinte, acestea sunt stări ale unui qubit care pot fi reprezentate prin matrice densitate, dar nu prin vectori de stare ai unui qubit.
Un aspect fundamental al bilei Bloch și al modului în care punctele interioare reprezintă stările impure este că
combinațiile convexe ale punctelor din interiorul bilei Bloch corespund combinațiilor convexe ale matricelor densitate.
Vorbind intuitiv, asta înseamnă că geometria continuă să funcționeze perfect chiar și în interiorul bilei
Bloch. Să aruncăm o privire la câteva exemple, începând cu punctul central al bilei Bloch, care reprezintă
starea complet mixtă. Starea complet mixtă se obține prin medierea stărilor zero și unu, ceea ce este consistent cu faptul
că centrul sferei este exact la jumătatea distanței între Polul Nord și Polul Sud, și de fapt este la jumătatea distanței între orice două puncte antipodale, cum ar fi
stările plus și minus și stările plus I și minus I. Punctele antipodale pe sfera Bloch corespund întotdeauna
stărilor pure ortogonale, și ceea ce aceasta revelează sau reflectă este că putem scrie întotdeauna starea complet mixtă
ca medie între orice două stări pure ortogonale ale unui qubit. O altă modalitate de a vedea asta este să
gândi la reprezentarea prin matrice Pauli a stării complet mixte. Pentru ca asta să funcționeze trebuie să setăm
coeficienții pe toate cele trei matrice Pauli non-identitate la zero, deci punctul corespunzător din interiorul
bilei Bloch este chiar în centru, la origine. Apropo, a gândi la reprezentările prin matrice Pauli ale matricelor
densitate ca aceasta face de fapt destul de clar că combinațiile convexe ale punctelor bilei Bloch corespund combinațiilor
convexe ale matricelor densitate: dacă luăm o medie sau o medie ponderată a matricelor densitate și
exprimăm totul în termeni de combinații liniare ale matricelor Pauli, atunci desigur facem pur și simplu media punctelor corespunzătoare deoarece totul
este liniar în acei trei coeficienți. Pentru încă un exemplu, să considerăm media stării zero
și a stării plus, pe care am văzut-o mai devreme în lecție. Am calculat reprezentarea prin matrice densitate, care este prezentată pe
ecran, și avem că punctul se află în interiorul bilei Bloch, la jumătatea distanței între stările zero și plus.
Am văzut, de asemenea, că putem exprima această matrice densitate într-un mod diferit pe baza descompunerii sale spectrale și
din nou asta este consistent cu diagrama și exemplele anterioare. Și aceasta încheie
discuția despre sfera Bloch și bila Bloch. Oamenii întreabă adesea dacă există o sferă Bloch sau o bilă Bloch pentru sisteme cu
trei sau mai multe stări clasice, și răspunsul nefericit este: nu chiar. Putem gândi întotdeauna la
stările cuantice ale unui sistem în termeni geometrici similari cu bila Bloch și vom obține un corp convex într-un spațiu vectorial real,
dar dacă avem trei sau mai multe stări clasice nu va fi sferic. De exemplu, dacă avem
exact trei stări clasice, adică un qutrit, vom obține un corp convex într-un spațiu de opt dimensiuni,
dar punctele extreme ale acelui corp, care corespund stărilor cuantice pure ale unui qutrit, vor fi numai
patru-dimensionale. Dacă reușești să vizualizezi o varietate de patru dimensiuni într-un spațiu de opt dimensiuni și să o "înfășori" oarecum pentru a obține un corp convex
și găsești asta o modalitate utilă de a gândi la qutriti, atunci cu atât mai bine. Este interesant de
gândit, dar nu este o bilă, este mai complicat decât atât. În ultima parte a lecției vom discuta pe scurt
cum funcționează matricele densitate pentru sisteme multiple. Matricele densitate pot reprezenta stări ale sistemelor multiple și asta
funcționează într-un mod complet analog cu vectorii de stare cuantică. În particular, la fel cum avem în formularea simplificată a informației
cuantice, putem privi sistemele multiple împreună ca și cum ar fi sisteme compuse
singulare. De data aceasta, atât liniile cât și coloanele matricelor densitate care reprezintă stări ale sistemelor multiple sunt
puse în corespondență cu produsul cartezian al mulțimilor de stări clasice ale sistemelor individuale. De exemplu, putem considera
reprezentările prin matrice densitate ale celor patru stări Bell, pe care le obținem exact la fel cum am procedat pentru alți
vectori de stare cuantică mai devreme în lecție, înmulțind vectorii de stare cu conjugatele lor transpuse, iar rezultatele sunt prezentate pe
ecran. În esență, nu există nimic nou la nivel conceptual, deși vom vedea imediat că există câteva
lucruri noi pe care le putem face cu matricele densitate pentru sisteme multiple. Noțiunile de independență și
corelații se transferă de la vectorii de stare cuantică la matricele densitate și, în particular, constatăm că produsele tensoriale
ale matricelor densitate reprezintă independența dintre sisteme. Folosim aceeași terminologie ca
pentru vectorii de stare cuantică. De exemplu, dacă avem un sistem X pregătit în starea rho și un sistem Y
pregătit independent în starea sigma, atunci starea perechii XY împreună este dată de produsul tensorial
al lui rho și sigma. Numim aceasta o stare produs și se generalizează în mod natural la mai mult de două
sisteme. Matricele densitate care nu pot fi exprimate ca stări produs reprezintă corelații între sisteme și
asta este similar cu vectorii de stare cuantică, dar după cum se dovedește, există diferite tipuri de corelații care pot apărea când folosim matrice densitate, chiar și pentru
doar două sisteme. Prin contrast, cu vectorii de stare cuantică există cu adevărat un singur tip de corelație pe care o putem avea
și aceea este entanglementul. A spune altfel, corelația și entanglementul sunt sinonime pentru vectorii de stare cuantică, dar
WEBVTT
asta nu este adevărat pentru matricele densitate. Aici lucrurile sunt mai interesante. De exemplu, putem descrie
stări clasice corelate cu matrice densitate. Iată un exemplu de matrice densitate reprezentând un bit aleatoriu clasic
partajat între Alice și Bob. Ei au întotdeauna aceeași stare clasică, zero sau unu, și probabilitățile sunt
1/2 pentru fiecare dintre posibilități. Aceasta nu este o stare entanglată; entanglementul este non-clasic, dar
este o stare corelată. Un alt exemplu este conectat cu noțiunea de ansamblu de stări cuantice,
pe care o poți gândi ca o distribuție de probabilitate peste o mulțime finită de stări cuantice. În particular, să ne imaginăm că
avem m matrice densitate rho zero până la rho m minus unu, toate reprezentând stări posibile ale unui anumit sistem,
împreună cu o probabilitate de a trage fiecare dintre ele. Dacă am vrea, am putea calcula media ponderată a acestor matrice
densitate luând o combinație convexă a lor, dar asta nu ne-ar spune de fapt care sunt stările individuale sau care sunt
probabilitățile. Ceea ce putem face în schimb, și este destul de util uneori, este să considerăm o matrice
densitate de forma prezentată pe ecran. Aceasta este o stare a două sisteme în care primul sistem are o stare clasică
pentru fiecare dintre alternative și luăm media ponderată a m stări produs, unde starea primului sistem
este întotdeauna clasică și etichetează în esență care dintre cele m stări avem pentru al doilea
sistem. Dacă nu este clar exact de ce am vrea să gândim la stări ca acestea, este în regulă; este doar un exemplu de
un tip de corelație în care primul sistem este întotdeauna clasic și al doilea sistem poate fi într-o stare
cuantică. O a treia categorie de stări posibil corelate este mulțimea stărilor așa-numite separabile.
Pe scurt, acestea sunt combinații convexe ale stărilor produs și reprezintă în esență stări cuantice
în care orice corelații dintre sisteme sunt corelații clasice. O modalitate de a gândi la
stări ca acestea este că facem o selecție probabilistică pentru un număr k și apoi pregătim independent două
sisteme într-o stare cuantică care poate depinde de această alegere a lui k. Ceea ce este poate cel mai interesant despre
stările de această formă este că aceasta este de fapt modul în care definim entanglementul în termeni matematici. În particular, entanglementul este
definit ca o lipsă a separabilității, deci dacă ai o matrice densitate și nu este posibil să o exprimi într-o formă
ca aceasta, atunci prin definiție este entanglată. Am aluzat la asta în lecția 4 și iată-o în mai
mare detaliu. Apropo, poate fi foarte dificil să determini dacă o matrice densitate dată reprezintă o stare
entanglată, chiar și cu ajutorul unui calculator. Matematic și computațional vorbind, entanglementul este
de fapt destul de complicat. Am menționat la începutul lecției că există un lucru foarte important pe care îl putem face cu matricele densitate și
anume să descriem stările unor părți izolate ale sistemelor chiar și atunci când sunt corelate și posibil entanglate cu alte
sisteme. Termenul stare redusă este adesea folosit în acest context și, ca exemplu simplu, vom calcula stările reduse
pentru qubiții individuali care formează un ebit. Mai precis, să presupunem că
Alice și Bob împart un ebit: Alice deține qubit-ul A, Bob deține qubit-ul B, și împreună acești doi qubiți se află în starea phi
plus. Întrebarea la care vom răspunde este care este starea qubit-ului A al lui Alice în
izolare. Desigur, am putea pune aceeași întrebare pentru qubit-ul lui Bob, dar este ușor să răspundem la acea întrebare odată ce cunoaștem răspunsul la aceasta.
Acum, ar putea fi tentant să spunem că nu putem descrie starea qubit-ului lui Alice în izolare deoarece este
entanglat cu qubit-ul lui Bob, ceea ce poate cumva ne-ar interzice să descriem sau chiar să gândim la starea lui A în
izolare, dar acest lucru este fals. Este adevărat că nu putem descrie starea lui A cu un vector de stare
cuantică, deoarece după cum vom vedea nu se află într-o stare pură, dar fiecare sistem are o stare în orice moment dat care poate fi
descrisă de o matrice densitate, indiferent dacă este entanglat cu alt sistem sau nu. Ca experiment de gândire, doar pentru a ne ajuta
să vedem care este răspunsul la această întrebare, să presupunem că Bob decide să ia qubit-ul lui și să plece spre stele și nu se mai aude
niciodată de el. Dar imaginează-ți că undeva pe parcurs decide să efectueze o măsurătoare în baza standard pe qubit-ul
său. Știm cum să calculăm probabilitățile pentru el de a obține cele două rezultate posibile și știm și care
va fi starea lui A pentru fiecare rezultat posibil, și acele lucruri sunt rezumate în acest tabel. În particular, cu probabilitate 1/2
A va fi lăsat în starea zero și cu probabilitate 1/2 A va fi lăsat în starea unu, deci după cum a fost discutat mai devreme în
lecție, aceasta îl lasă pe A în starea complet mixtă și prin urmare acesta este răspunsul
la întrebarea noastră. Acum ai putea obiecta și spune că acesta depinde de faptul că
Bob a decis să măsoare qubit-ul lui și presupunerea că face asta face parte din povestea care ne-a condus la acest răspuns, dar
dacă Bob se află la ani lumină distanță până când măsoară, nimic din ceea ce face nu ar putea influența niciun
experiment pe care Alice ar decide să îl efectueze pe qubit-ul ei, altfel am avea o comunicare mai rapidă decât lumina.
Deci qubit-ul lui Alice este în starea complet mixtă indiferent dacă Bob
măsoară sau nu. Trebuie să clarific la acest punct că noțiunea de stare redusă și modul în care sunt definite nu depind cu adevărat de relativitate
sau de imposibilitatea comunicării mai rapide decât lumina. Aceasta este doar o modalitate de a explica în termeni, sperăm, intuitivi.
În realitate, există o definiție matematică pe care o vom vedea într-un context mai general în câteva momente. Este consistent cu acest răspuns
și în mod coincident cu imposibilitatea comunicării mai rapide decât lumina, și nu există nicio altă
definiție care ar putea fi consistentă cu informația cuantică așa cum o cunoaștem. Acum să considerăm stările reduse în mai mare
generalitate. Să presupunem că avem o pereche de sisteme A și B, nu neapărat qubiți, care se află împreună într-o stare pură
reprezentată de un vector de stare cuantică psi. Din nou, ne vom concentra pe starea redusă a sistemului A, și pentru a face
asta va fi util să gândim la stările clasice ale sistemului B. Deci, fie gamma această mulțime de
stări clasice ale lui B. După cum am discutat înainte, în lecția 2 a seriei de exemplu,
există o colecție unică de vectori phi b pentru fiecare b din Gamma pentru care expresia lui psi prezentată pe ecran
este corectă, și în particular există o formulă simplă pentru acești vectori: înmulțim pur și simplu vectorul psi cu
produsul tensorial al matricei identitate corespunzătoare sistemului A cu bra b pentru oricare b care ne interesează.
Ceea ce facem aici este practic să ne pregătim să calculăm ce s-ar întâmpla dacă am efectua o
WEBVTT
măsurătoare în baza standard pe B, și din nou asta a fost abordat în lecția 2 a
seriei. Deci, dacă am efectua o măsurătoare în baza standard pe B, fiecare rezultat posibil ar apărea
cu o probabilitate egală cu norma euclidiană la pătrat a vectorului corespunzător phi b, și condiționat de obținerea unui
rezultat particular b, normalizăm vectorul phi b pentru a determina starea rezultantă a
lui A. Urmând același raționament ca în exemplul cu ebitul de mai sus, obținem expresia prezentată pe
ecran pentru starea redusă a lui A ca matrice densitate, și apropo, norma la pătrat din numitor provine din
înmulțirea vectorului normalizat cu conjugatul său transpus, deci obținem norma euclidiană de două ori în
numitor, normele euclidiene la pătrat se simplifică și rămânem cu o expresie destul de simplă.
Și de fapt, dacă substituim formula pentru phi b, care funcționează pentru orice b, obținem o formulă pentru starea redusă
a sistemului A în termenii descrierii prin matrice densitate a stării pure cu care am început, adică ket psi
bra psi. Deci aceasta este formula noastră pentru starea redusă a sistemului A, presupunând că sistemul compus AB a pornit în
starea psi. Dar putem folosi formula și mai general. În particular, să presupunem
că starea lui AB este dată de o matrice densitate rho, care ar putea lua forma ket psi bra psi pentru un vector de stare
cuantică psi, dar nu neapărat. Urmează practic prin liniaritate că starea redusă a lui A este
determinată de aceeași formulă pe care o aveam pentru stările pure, cu excepția că substituim orice matrice densitate rho
dorim. Ca notație prescurtată, este destul de obișnuit să denotăm această stare redusă prin orice nume folosim pentru
matricea densitate rho în acest caz, dar punem un subscript care indică sistemul pe care ne concentrăm. Deci rho cu un
subscript A înseamnă starea redusă a lui A atunci când sistemul compus se află în starea rho. Superscripturile sunt, de asemenea, uneori folosite
în loc de subscripturi; este practic o preferință personală și înseamnă același
lucru. Ne-am concentrat pe sistemul A doar pentru simplitate, dar putem obține și starea redusă a sistemului B
în mod analog, dar unde formula este adaptată în mod natural. Totul este simetric; practic
schimbăm rolurile lui A și B, și în particular suma se efectuează acum peste stările clasice ale lui A
mai degrabă decât ale lui B, și în formula de pe ecran presupunem că mulțimea stărilor clasice ale lui A se numește
Sigma. Toate acestea se generalizează în mod destul de direct la trei sau mai multe sisteme. De exemplu, dacă avem trei
sisteme A, B și C care se află colectiv în starea descrisă de matricea densitate rho, atunci putem obține
starea redusă a perechii AB împreună prin formula prezentată aici, precum și starea celui de-al treilea sistem singur
prin a doua formulă, și poți considera alte combinații și generaliza aceasta la oricâte sisteme dorești. Sumele sunt întotdeauna luate peste
mulțimile de stări clasice ale sistemelor care sunt ignorate, iar tiparul este întotdeauna același, cu matricea
densitate cu care am pornit fiind "sandwichată" între produsul tensorial al matricei identitate și bra-uri și ket-uri corespunzătoare
stărilor din baza standard. Pentru a încheia lecția, voi spune doar câteva cuvinte în plus despre definițiile pe care le-am acoperit tocmai. Operația pe matrice
densitate care descrie stările reduse are un nume și se numește urma parțială. Pentru două sisteme A și B,
urma parțială după B și urma parțială după A sunt definite după cum este arătat pe ecran. Acestea sunt exact aceleași
formule pe care le-am văzut mai sus și acum le gândim pur și simplu ca funcții de rho și le
dăm nume. Numele arată ca urma, cu excepția că există un subscript care ne spune care sistem este eliminat,
adică care sistem este cel a cărui mulțime de stări clasice o sumăm și care este "sandwichată" între un bra și un
ket. Când luăm urma parțială a lui rho B, de exemplu, care este descrisă de prima formulă, uneori spunem că
B este "eliminat prin urmă" și la fel pentru A. Intuitiv vorbind, eliminarea prin urmă a unui
sistem înseamnă pur și simplu că îl aruncăm sau îl ignorăm. Aceasta este o modalitate de a defini urma
parțială, iar o altă modalitate echivalentă este să spunem că aceste funcții sunt unicele funcții liniare care satisfac
formulele prezentate pe dreapta. Mai exact, dacă avem un produs tensorial a două matrice M și N, să
spunem, și efectuăm urma parțială peste primul sistem, atunci ceea ce obținem este urma primei matrice M înmulțită cu
a doua matrice N, și condiția este simetrică atunci când facem urma parțială peste al doilea sistem. Nu orice matrice pe care am calcula
urma parțială este un produs tensorial ca acesta, dar orice matrice poate fi exprimată ca o combinație liniară de
produse tensoriale și putem determina urma parțială din aceste condiții împreună cu faptul că acestea sunt funcții liniare.
Și de aceea se numește urma parțială. Această definiție echivalentă poate fi
destul de utilă deoarece putem folosi adesea această definiție mai degrabă decât formula originală. Iată un exemplu care
ilustrează asta. Să presupunem că avem o pereche de qubiți A și B în starea a cărei matrice densitate este prezentată pe
ecran. Acesta este un exemplu de stare corelată în care A se află fie în starea zero, fie în starea unu, fiecare
cu probabilitate 1/2, deci putem gândi la A ca la un sistem clasic. Dacă A este în starea zero, atunci
la fel este și B, iar dacă A este în starea unu, atunci B este în starea plus. Dacă vrem să știm care este starea redusă a lui A,
facem urma parțială după B, și dacă folosim a doua formulă din definiția echivalentă împreună cu liniaritatea, atunci putem
calcula asta destul de ușor. În particular, urma lui ket 0 bra 0 este unu, la fel și urma lui ket plus bra
plus, deci acei factori tensoriali dispar și rămânem cu starea complet mixtă. Pe linii similare, putem calcula
starea redusă a lui B făcând urma parțială după A. De data aceasta este primul factor tensorial pe care efectuăm urma, deci
folosim prima formulă din definiția echivalentă și rămânem cu 1/2 ori ket 0 bra 0 plus 1/2 ori ket
plus bra plus, adică cu alte cuvinte aceeași matrice densitate care a apărut de câteva ori anterior. Ai obține exact
aceleași rezultate dacă ai folosi formulele din prima definiție, dar aceasta este o modalitate mult mai ușoară de a o face. Aceasta se generalizează la trei sau mai multe
sisteme, dar pentru acest videoclip mă voi opri aici și las asta pentru tine să consideri pe cont propriu. Și aceasta este tot pentru această lecție, care
a introdus matricele densitate și a descris noțiunile de bază ale funcționării lor. Am discutat, de asemenea, sfera Bloch,
precum și diferite tipuri de corelații și noțiunea de stare redusă a unui sistem. Sper că te vei alătura pentru
următoarea lecție, care tratează canalele, adică funcțiile liniare de la matricele densitate la matricele densitate care
WEBVTT
descriu operații pe sisteme. La revedere până
atunci.